chris is with us in New York hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up well my wife and I are in baby
step two and got some credit card debts
and student loan debt and I recently got
a couple letters from the banks that own
a couple of the credit cards offering me
to settle for for 10% I'm wondering
number one should I take it and number
two should I be concerned about the tax
implications
well it's if you don't take it you pay a
lot more than you do plus tax
implications so you do have tax
implications forgiven debt is considered
taxable income they will send you a 1099
for the amount that they forgive and so
how far behind are you on these cards
that they voluntarily offer you a dime
on a dollar
yeah pretty far behind it back in
[Music]
2012-2013 I tried to switch careers and
work for an insurance company and
needless to say it didn't work out and I
thought you know I was optimistic I
tried to you know I figured I'll just
put on some credit cards and never paid
them for eight years I couldn't I
couldn't you know I mean I was so far
behind though so almost practically I
did give up on them yeah so what do you
what's the balance on the cards and so
what's that you know they my entire
credit card debt or just the two that
they offered you that they offered well
the one of them the balance is we're
here 1922 and the other one was a bigger
one it was sixteen thousand five hundred
eighty-three yeah so twenty-six hundred
bucks
I'm sorry no 1700 bucks clears up
seventeen thousand dollars worth of debt
that's a that's up your life yeah you
find that money and you make that happen
now not worried about my credit score
huh it's firm since 2012 you don't have
a credit score yeah I guess you got a
point yeah but glad I called it's not
time now to worry about your credit so
yeah let's get let's get rid of that and
get it in writing you do have it in
writing the deadline by which you can
pay this right yeah that's it has it a
letterhead on it has it all its got the
exes with the last four digits of
account number on it it's got everything
yeah okay and then no electronic access
to your checking
as the method of payment just get a Visa
prepaid card or or you know set up a
separate account because I don't want
them cleaning out your regular account
because sometimes they lie
who are the two cards with their with
case both of them are with Chase okay
and they say money orders accepted I
probably just do that yeah that'd be
perfect yeah okay and that I call yeah
double check with them on the phone
before you send the money and you've got
it in writing and then follow up with
the money keep records proof of the
money send the money return receipt
requested certified mail so you know it
came or FedEx where do they sign for it
or at least you know they got it that
way and then when the check clears you
need proof that it cleared keep hard
copies of that in a file for the rest of
your life because this may come up again
because they have weird memories at
these banks like they lie so um just
keep the rack keeps solid records on
what has happened here and now let's get
about the business of cleaning up the
rest of this mess okay now it's time
this is you've got a break here caught a
break now let's use it to clean up the
rest of it get on your budget get tight
let's get things moving the way they're
supposed to